[Music]
it used to be thought that being
bilingual was a bad thing that it would
confuse or hold people back especially
children turns out we couldn't have been
more wrong learning new languages is an
exercise of the mind it's the mental
equivalent of going to a gym every
[Music]
day in the bilingual brain all our
languages are active all at the same
time the continue effort of suppressing
a language when speaking another along
with a mental challenge that comes with
regularly switching between languages
exercises our brain it improves our
concentration problem solving memory and
in turn our
creativity it's now widely accepted that
there are huge benefits to being
bilingual a key breakthrough came back
in 2007 in Toronto when Ellen B alisto
and her team made a discovery that shook
the scientific community and has massive
real world
implications it was the first study
which suggested that bilingual people
people who speak more than one language
develop dementia four to 4 and a half
years later than those who don't it was
a powerful confirmation of the idea of
cognitive
Reserve now what is cognitive Reserve
cognitive Reserve is the idea that
people develop a reserve of thinking
abilities and this protects them against
losses that can occur through aging and
disease as well as delaying the onset of
dementia bilingual people have been
shown to recover significantly better
after a stroke learning anything new
helps build cognitive Reserve but
there's something special about language
language is particularly Broad and
complex it affects ideas and Concepts
perception different sounds the more
complex a certain skill is the more
likely it is to have a positive effect
on cognitive
Reserve so when is the best time to
learn a new language well here's part of
the
answer the brain is a complex set of new
networks when you're learning a new
language as a child you're building new
[Music]
networks but when you learn a language
later in life you have to modify the
existing
networks and make more
connections because learning languages
later in life can be more challenging
the benefits can also be
greater but a 2023 study at Great Orman
Street suggests this is just part of the
story so we invited three groups of
children that were aged 8 to 10 and we
had a group of children who were
monolingual
a group of children who had early
exposure to Greek and English from birth
they were our early bilinguals and
finally we had a group who had been
exposed to English between the ages of 2
and five and they were our later
bilinguals so what we did that no one
had done before is that we asked the
children to line the scanner while doing
nothing and just staring at a cross and
during this we measured their brain
activity so what we found that was
really exciting for us is that our early
bilingual group had the strongest
connectivity in a network at rest and
these group of regions are regions that
light up when we're doing nothing and
just mind wandering a little bit like if
you're going to the gym every day your
muscles might look bigger at rest where
similarly your brain might be better
connected at rest because you are
learning a language early and this is
something no one had found
before and there's more one lesser known
behavioral effect of bilingualism in
both children and adults is the ability
to to see the other people's perspective
or to understand that it is possible to
have different points of view recent
Studies have also found that people tend
to react more emotionally in their first
language and more rational in a more
abstract way in the second and the way
it is usually explained is that the
first language is the one which we use
to speak with family with friends in
informal settings the language is
usually learned at school at the
University at
work scientists are discovering new
upsides to be in bilingual all the time
and it's not just our brains that
benefit learning new languages and
speaking more than one language is very
important not only for individuals but
also for societies learning new
languages can open doors to new cultural
experiences life opportunities different
people different communities and
different ways of seeing the
world and with that we'll say a
[Music]
final
goodbye
bye po
V thanks for watching if you enjoyed
that be sure to check out these videos
next and if you haven't already hit the
sub subscribe button and click the Bell
to get a notification each time we
upload a new video